Cells are the smallest living units of
an organism.
All cells have three things in
common
no matter what type of cell they are.
All cells have a cell membrane which separates the
inside the cell from its environment,
cytoplasm, which is a jelly-like fluid,
and DNA which is the cell's genetic
material.
There are two broad categories of cells.
The first category is eukaryotic cells.
They have organelles
which include the nucleus and other
special parts.
Eukaryotic cells are more advanced,
complex cells
such as those found in plants and
animals.
The second category is prokaryotic
cells.
They don't have a nucleus or membrane
enclosed organelles.
They do have genetic material but it's
not contained within a nucleus.
Prokaryotic cells are always one celled,
or unicellular organisms, such as
bacteria.
So what are organelles?
Organelle means "little organ."
Organelles are the specialized parts of a cell that have unique jobs to perform.
Let's start with the nucleus, the
control center of the cell.
The nucleus contains DNA or genetic
material.
DNA dictates what the cell is going
to do
and how it's going to do it.
Chromatin the tangled, spread out form of DNA
found inside the nuclear membrane.
When a cell is ready to divide
DNA condenses into structures known as
chromosomes.
The nucleus also contains a nucleolus,
which is a structure where ribosomes
are made.
After ribosomes leave the nucleus
they will have the important job  of "synthesizing",
or making, proteins.
Outside the nucleus the ribosomes and
the rest of the organelles
float around in cytoplasm, which is the
jelly-like substance.
Ribosomes may wander freely within
the cytoplasm
or attach to the endoplasmic
reticulum, sometimes abbreviated as ER.
There are two types of ER:
rough ER has ribosomes attached to it
and smooth ER doesn't have
ribosomes attached to it.
The endoplasmic reticulum
is a membrane enclosed passageway for
transporting materials
such as the proteins synthesized by
ribosomes.
Proteins and other materials
emerge from the endoplasmic reticulum
in small vesicles
where the Golgi apparatus, sometimes called the Golgi body
receives them.
As proteins move through the Golgi body
they're customized
into forms that the cell can use.
The Golgi body does this by folding the
proteins into usable shapes.
or adding other materials on to them
such as lipids
or carbohydrates
Vacuoles are sac-like structures that store
different materials.
Here, in this plant cell, the central vacuole stores water.
Going back to the animal cell,
you'll see an organelle called a lysosome.
Lysosomes are the garbage collectors
that take in damaged or worn out cell parts.
They are filled with enzymes that break
down this cellular debris.
The mitochondrion in is an organelle
that is the powerhouse for both
animal and plant cells.
During a process called cellular respiration
the mitochondria make ATP molecules
that provide the energy for all the
cells activities.
Cells that need more energy
have more mitochondria.
Meanwhile the cell maintains its shape
through a cytoskeleton.
The cytoskeleton includes the thread-like microfilaments
which are made of protein
and microtubules which are thin hollow tubes
Some organisms
such as plans that are photoautotrophic
meaning they capture sunlight for energy
have cells with an organelle called
a chloroplast.
The chloroplast is where
photosynthesis happens
It's green because it has a green
pigment called
chlorophyll.
Plant cells also have a cell wall
outside of their cell membranes
that shape, support, and protect the plant cell.
Animal cells never have a cell wall
There are many other unique
structures that only some cells have.
Here are just a few.
In humans, for example, the respiratory tract is lined with cells that have cilia.
These are microscopic
hair-like projections
that can move in waves.
This feature helps trap inhaled particles in the air and expels them when you cough.
Another unique feature in some cells is flagella.
Some bacteria have flagella.
A flagellum is like a little tail that
can help a cell move or propel itself.
The only human cell that has a flagellum
is a sperm cell.
In summary remember:
eukaryotic cells are plant and animal cells with a nucleus and membrane-enclosed organelles
While prokaryotic cells are unicellular organisms without these things.
All cells have a cell membrane, cytoplasm and genetic material.
And even though only plant cells have
chloroplasts
both plant and animal cells have mitochondria.